what is actually happening to us is
pretty darn hard to wrap your mind
around we are caught in a vortex of
concrescence and compression that was
set in motion at least as early as the
melting of the last glaciation we are
reaping the fruits of ten thousand fifty
thousand years of sowing of the fields
of mind and it is being dropped into our
lives for us to create you know human
machine interface in control of genetic
material redefinition of social reality
re-engineering of languages revision
aplanet area ecology all these things
fall upon us and for us to be worthy of
it for us to make sense of it for us to
be anything other than victimized by the
20th century we need I think to reach
back into time and to anchor ourselves
with the transcendent mystery which is
somehow tied up with our own being
somehow present on the planet but mostly
a large list of unanswered questions we
don't know what is going on on this
planet we don't know why there is life
here whether it's an accident somebody's
plan we don't know why intelligence is
here again accident plan if plan whose
plan if plan for what if plan where are
we in the plan
I mean we all tend when we abandon
ourselves to cultural values to focus in
so tightly that we lose the big picture
and excited Daleks are anything they are
a zoom lens back to the broad possible
point of view
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't know where we came from you
know what lies beyond the zygote and we
don't know where we're going what lies
beyond the pine box
who can say so out of the incredible
mystery of whatever the universe is a
second of opportunity against impossible
odds has sprung into being we are
embedded in that moment of opportunity
so what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
you